Wie sollte es anders kommen? Natürlich trifft Edin Dzeko bei seinem ersten Spiel für Schalke 04. Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage, trägt er die Königsblauen auch zum Aufstieg? Und die zweite Frage, wie sind eigentlich die anderen Zweitligisten, die sind ja auch durchaus mal Thema, aus der Winterpause gekommen? Das bespreche ich nun mit Matthias Kneifl und Kevin Bublitz. Let's go! Jetzt nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Langeheil fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin, Wagner.
Und das Anzündung.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, einen erstaunlich guten. Also gegen Hannover 3 zu 1 zu gewinnen, da hatte ich so leichte Darmstadt-Erinnerungen. Also sprich Hannover gegen in Führung und dann kam irgendwann die Wucht des FCK natürlich noch ein bisschen mit, profitiert von einem Platzverweis für Hannover, der ein bisschen dämlich war. Aber nun denn, da hat Kaislautern die Chance ergriffen, hat das Spiel gedreht, 3 zu 1 gewonnen. Und heute war ich primär gespannt, wie sie auswärts auftreten, weil das doch so ein bisschen die Arillisferse des FCK ist. Da haben sie vor dem Spiel, meine ich, bislang erst acht Punkte geholt, jetzt sind es dann eben neun. Und vielleicht haben die ein oder anderen von uns noch den Auftritt in Bielefeld vor Augen, wo Kais Lauthorn quasi Anti-Fußball gespielt hat. Und sich von Anfang an nur mit dem Willen, einen Punkt mitzunehmen, da ja so angetreten ist und den er auch gezogen hat. Aber es war für ein Team, das eher nach oben schielt, ernüchternd bis erschreckend damals, die Performance. Und deshalb war ich gespannt, ob sie da heute eh nicht agieren, aber sie haben es anders gemacht. Also sie haben so ein bisschen den Ansatz gefahren, Safety First, aber sie sind sehr schnell ausgeschwärmt. Also sie hatten mit Ritzas, Gütey und Bassett, der neu gekommen ist zur Winterpause, dann den schnellen, direkten Weg nach vorne gesucht. Und das hat lange nicht gefruchtet, aber dennoch haben sie Schalke beschäftigen können. Und dann gibt es so jemanden wie Briteien, den sie von der Bank bringen können, der dann auch noch prompt mit seiner quasi Eingabe den 1 zu 0 Treffer macht und dann auch noch super stark den Konter zu Ende fährt, zum 2 zu 0. Was zeigt, die haben sich eine Taktik zurechtgelegt, die funktioniert. Also sie haben erst mal hinten versucht, nicht sonderlich viel anbrennen zu lassen und dann sehr zielgerichtet nach vorne zu spielen oder eben auch mal so ein Standard zu nutzen. Und es hätte ja fast zu einem Dreier geführt, aber dann gab es eben so ein Betze-Moment in umgekehrter Form, nämlich dass auch Schalke daheim gerne mal einen Rückstand zumindest egalisieren kann. Also das fand ich schon bemerkenswert abgezockt, könnte man sagen, wie laut und aufgetreten ist. Und was man eben auch sieht, sie können inzwischen auf einen breiteren Kader setzen. Also wer von der Bank, Parteien, Schahin und Hans Lig bringen kann, das wäre wahrscheinlich in der Vorrunde nicht immer gegangen, weil sie doch immer mal wieder Lücken im Kader hatten. Oder eben Leute, die das Niveau nicht so wirklich halten können. Und deshalb ist es vielleicht auch ein kleiner Faktor, dass sie jetzt gerade viele an Bord haben, die dann auch wiederum Optionen sind, im Spielverlauf ihren Stempel zu hinterlassen oder ihren Eindruck zu machen auf das Team und auf den Spielverlauf. Und jetzt spielen sie als nächstes gegen Elbersberg und in der Amstatt. Also sie haben weiter die Gelegenheit, Boden gut zu machen gegen direkte Kontrahenten. Und ganz weit geblickt, das Ende der Saison sind dann eher gegen vermeintlich leichtere Gegner. Zumindest Braunschweig, Dresden, Bielefeld, Magdeburg. Wenn die im Abstiegskampf stehen, ist das kein Selbstläufer. Aber zumindest haben sie erst mal die Big Fish am Anfang der Rückrunde. Also mal gucken, was da sich so entwickelt. Und mich haben sie wirklich sehr überrascht. Gleichwohl, ein Jamfie hat auch gemerkt zum Schluss, ein Dzeko ist nicht Gommis. Den konnte er locker abkochen zwei, dreimal in der ersten Halbzeit. Dzeko blieb standhaft und hat den Anschlusstreffer gemacht.
Ja, ja, ich kann die Taktik von Karsten Sartor auf jeden Fall verstehen zu sagen, zu Hause setzen wir auf den Betze-Bonus. Ist ja auch einfach. Also es funktioniert ja so, das ist ja kein bangen und hoffen, sondern es funktioniert ja wirklich da, so eine Wucht zu entwickeln. Und auswärts werden wir richtig humorlos sein. Gegen Bielefeld fand ich tatsächlich fast ein bisschen unwürdig dieses Spiel. Aber auf Schalke zu sagen, ey, soll Schalke doch erst mal machen mit dem Ball? Gucken wir mal. Und zur Not sind wir da über Konter- oder Standard-Situationen. Das finde ich jetzt in Ordnung. Also wenn sich Thorsten Dieberknecht vor dem Spiel hinstellt und sagt, ey, ganz ehrlich, eine Scheißleistung und drei Punkte gegen Schalke nehme ich, das kann ich irgendwo verstehen von der Herangehensweise her, weil alte Regel gewinnt sie jedes Heimspiel, spielt jedes Aussaatsspiel unentschieden, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich aufsteigen. Und dementsprechend ist das besonders gegen die Top-Teams natürlich ein legitimer Ansatz. Du hast es schon erwähnt. Norman Bassett haben sie sich nach vorne geholt. Der vielleicht noch ohne Tor da steht. Der aber ermöglicht durch seine reine Präsenz, dass ein Ivan Pratayan von der Bank kommen kann. Der nun mal aktuell körperlich noch nicht bei 100% ist, bei weitem nicht. Der aber dann seine entscheidenden Momente bekommt. Und jetzt in den beiden Spielen nach der Rückrunde oder nach dem Rückrundstart so schon wieder bei 3 Toren steht. Insgesamt übrigens bei 11, was gemessen in seiner Spielzeit lächerlich ist. Also es ist eine absurde Quote. Und hinten hat jetzt beispielsweise ja auch ein neuer gespielt. Athanas Scherneff, richtig bulliger Innenverteidiger, Bulgare, 1,95 groß, yo. Also das ist auch Zweitligamaterial, der da auch wieder ermöglicht, dass ein Jan Elvedi, der in der Hinrunde wirklich oft nicht gut aussah, da mal auf der Bank sitzen kann. Also man schafft sich so ein paar Möglichkeiten. Könnte sogar vorstellen, dass es vielleicht nicht die letzten Transfers sind. Sollte da Geld übrig sein, weil es gibt noch andere Problemzonen. Per se aber so schon mal ein runderer Kader mit einem okayen Ansatz. Ich bleibe aber kritisch und sage, man ist weiterhin sehr abhängig von Ivan Britein. Also sehr abhängig, ungesund abhängig, würde ich fast sagen. Man ist weiter, finde ich, im Spiel relativ eindimensional. Besonders, wenn Skewtick keinen fantastischen Tag erwischt, dann wird es kreativ extremst dünn. Ich glaube weiterhin nicht daran, dass Lautern letztendlich aufsteigen wird. Ich habe schon in der Vorschau gesagt, für mich ist es auf jeden Fall ein Top-7-Team. Also da gibt es gar keine Diskussion. Aber dann in die ersten drei zu kommen, besonders in die ersten zwei, das sehe ich nicht. Dafür werden sie zu viele Spiele, glaube ich, so ein bisschen zäh liegen lassen. Aber das ist ja okay und für den Start ist das jetzt wirklich sehr in Ordnung gewesen. Deswegen ist es vollkommen verdient bei Spielen gegen Hannover und Schalke, das muss man ja nochmal sagen, als Kontext vier Punkte zu holen, ist absolut verdient, dann hier genannt zu werden. Trotzdem bin ich skeptisch, was den weiteren Blick angeht. Kevin, wie würdest du die Schaumung des FCK…
Geht mir genauso, wenn ich da nochmal kurz einkrätschen darf. Also sehe ich genauso, auch da hat sich an meine Meinung von November wenig geändert. Da hatte ich auch schon gesagt, dass das am Ende wahrscheinlich zu wenig sein wird. Allerdings, wir kennen lieber Knecht. Er hat mit Underdog-Teams durchaus auch mit Braunschweig und Nachschluss den Aufstieg geschafft. Das ist ihm auch in Lautern zuzutrauen. Und er ist einfach ein pragmatischer Charakter. Also er versucht dann aus einer Mannschaft jetzt nicht, irgendwas herauf zu beschweren, was gar nicht drin steckt. Und das ist vielleicht mit einem Faustpfand jetzt für die nächsten Wochen und Monate. Aber ich glaube auch noch nicht so recht dran, dass da wirklich zum Schluss noch Lautern in der Verlosung ist. Aber jetzt gerne Kevin.
Da muss ich mich erst mal imuten. Ja, Casus Lauter und ich sind sowieso immer ein zwiegespaltenes Thema. Ich finde beachtlich, dass sie immer wieder in den letzten Jahren gute Stürmer entdecken, die ihnen helfen mit Ragnar Ache oder jetzt halt Britalien. Das ist schon– gerade in der 2. Liga, finde ich, ein enormes Faustpfand und bin aber gleichzeitig bei euch, dass das halt auch der Grund ist, warum sie gerade mit oben in der Verlosung sind und warum sie dann aber auch aus meiner Sicht den entscheidenden Schritt wahrscheinlich nicht machen werden am Ende. Weil so etwas fehlt, wie jetzt auf Schalke, das Spiel dann einzusacken. Ja, also das ist schon beachtlich gegen die direkten Konkurrenten, die da oben stehen, vier Punkte zu holen, alles cool. Jetzt kommen, du hast ja schon gesagt, Matthias, zwei weitere starke Gegner mit Elbersberg und dann halt Darmstadt. Ich meine, das ist schon ein ordentliches Programm in die Rückrunde. Und ich bin halt jetzt gespannt, was diese späte Schalke-Ausgleich, also diese Auffalljagd mit Kaiserslautern macht. Weil ich meine, wenn die mit einem 2-0-Von Schalke nach Hause fahren, dann haben sie, glaube ich, ein richtiges Momentum. Jetzt ärgern sie sich, glaube ich, maßlos, dass sie das so hergeschenkt haben noch oder zwei Punkte halt verloren haben. Bin echt gespannt. Aber wie gesagt, also sie haben halt einfach diese Stürmer als Riesenbonus. Auch im Vergleich zu anderen Mitkonkurrenten. Also wenn man jetzt Paderborn zum Beispiel sieht, die eher Probleme haben, Stürmer zu finden, der da vorne regelmäßig Tore schießt. Also es sind ja noch andere, die oben in der Verlosung mit sind, die dieses Problem haben. Das könnte, je nachdem, wenn Lieber, wenn ich das hinkriege, diese Aussetzer, nenn ich es mal, in den Griff zu kriegen, dann könnten sie trotzdem bis zum Ende oben mit dran bleiben. Und dann haben sie natürlich das vermeintlich leichteste Restprogramm von den Teams da oben. Aber ich traue den Braten auch nicht so richtig.
Das Interessante ist, dass wir ja eher bei Kreiserslautern die Spiele gegen die Teams von unten Sorgen machen, weil Ballbesitzspielen nicht die Stärke von Thorsten Lieberknecht ist und sie sich genau in diesen Spielen oft die Zähne ausbeißen, weil der Gegner sagt, naja, kommt doch. So, wir verteidigen einfach die Tiefe. Versucht doch mal dann mit euren Schienenspielern durchzubrechen und irgendeine gescheite Flanke auf verteilen zu bringen. Die kommt da gar nicht erst hin. Das sind eher die Spiele, wo ich das Gefühl habe, dass sich die Lauterer die Zähne ausbeißen. Diese offeneren Duelle, wo sie kontern können, wo sie Platz haben. Das sind dann die Spiele, die interessant für sie sind.
Ja, und sie hatten, glaube ich, jetzt vor dem Spiel gegen Schalke fünf Spiele davor, zwölf Gegentore kassiert, jetzt wieder zwei. Sie müssen also extrem viele Tore auch schießen, um dann ein Spiel zu gewinnen. Was natürlich auch ein immenser Kraftakt ist, den du auch erst mal über so eine ganze Serie hinkriegen musst. Also ich glaube, sie sind defensiv nicht gut genug aufgestellt, um letztendlich ganz oben zu landen.
Die Prognose nehmen wir doch mal so mit und wandern. Dementsprechend jetzt noch zu einem letzten Team, das wir kurz besprechen wollen, wenn wir schon mal den Experten da haben. Matthias, die Darmstädter, sie sind nicht von oben wegzubekommen. Im Gegenteil, sie beißen sich regelrecht fest und haben den Abstand auf Schalke jetzt auf zwei Punkte schmelzen lassen. Lassen wir noch mal kurz gucken. Das waren jetzt die Spiele 3-3 gegen Bochum und das 2-0 gegen Nürnberg. Jetzt ist man seit neun Spielen ohne Liederlage. Die letzte Nullnummer stammt vom 24. Oktober. Das war übrigens das 0-1 gegen Schalke. Also wenn das Spiel unentschieden ausgeht, dann ist es lustigerweise dann jetzt auch gerade zwei Punkte, die sie trennen. Wie blickst du gerade auf deine Lilien? Wie blickst du auf diesen Rückrundenstart?
Glück, würde ich sagen. Also in Bochum einen Punkt mitzunehmen, da darf man einverstanden sein, weil gerade ist halt Rösler da an der Seitenlinie steht bei Bochum. Da sind sie auch schwer zu besiegen. Und es war ein wildes Spiel, für meinen Begriff etwas zu wild. Kevin wird sich auch noch an das letzte Spiel vor der Winterpause erinnern, 2-2 in Paderborn. Da hatte Darmstadt 2-0 geführt und hat dann noch zwei Eier gefangen. Also das ist vielleicht auch so was, was mir im Hinblick auf Auswärtsspiele ein bisschen Sorgen bereitet. Und das nächste Auswärtsspiel steht ja jetzt am Wochenende bei Hertha an, dass sie sowohl in Paderborn als auch in Bochum im Laufe der zweiten Halbzeit nicht mehr wirklich aktiv waren. Also sie haben sich zu sehr in die Defensive fallen lassen, hatten nicht mehr die Spielanteile wie noch in der ersten Halbzeit. Und das war jetzt nicht zwingend in der Luft gelegen, in Bochum dann noch den dritten Treffer und damit den Ausgleich zu kassieren. In Paderborn gleich wohl schon. Also da war es für mich klar, da kannst du die Uhr danach stellen. Irgendwann geht es eben unentschieden aus. Und da waren sie auch im Nachhinein sehr kritisch. Also auch Kohfeldt und die Spieler, dass sie so nicht das Spiel zu Ende spielen wollten. Aber sie konnten offenbar in dem Moment nicht anders als das über sich ergehen lassen. Und da müssen sie schleunigst die richtigen Schlüsse draus ziehen. Aber wie auch immer, sie haben erst zwei Niederlagen im gesamten Saisonverlauf. Das heißt, es ist eine gewisse Stabilität da. Kofel sagte auch nach dem Spiel gegen Nürnberg, selbst wenn der Plan, den sie sich zurechtgelegt haben, nicht funktioniert, die Mannschaft wird nicht unruhig. Sie findet Wege ins Spiel zu kommen und dann auch Torabschlüsse zu generieren und auf genug Tore zu schießen. Sie sind jetzt mit, ich glaube, Kaiserslautern und Elbersberg, die treffen sich aus der Offensive. Und das gibt mir gleich wohl wieder ein bisschen Zuversicht. Also sie finden es immer wieder doch zurück ins Spiel und wissen dann auch nach vorne ihre Chancen oft genug zu nutzen. Und deshalb, gegen Nürnberg lief auch nicht von Anfang an alles in die Richtung der Lilien, aber sie schaffen es dann einfach auch, den Gegnern nicht jetzt nur rechts und links zur Seite zu stehen und zu sagen, bitte marschier durch und mach das Tor, sondern sie erwähnen sich. Aber so ein richtiges Spitzen-Team bin ich mir nicht immer sicher, ob sie das tatsächlich sind, auch wenn sie gerade Zweiter sind. Aber so richtig traue ich dem ganzen Braten tatsächlich nicht. Marc überraschend klingen bei so einer stabilen Tabellensituation und auch den letzten Ergebnissen. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie seht ihr das als Außenstehende? Ich bin da noch so ein bisschen im Wasserstand.
Also ich finde sie, wenn ich dazu sagen darf, ich finde sie halt unspektakulär. Und das ist einfach das, was sie von Schalke zum Beispiel mit dem ganzen Primorium drum herum unterscheidet. Oder Kaiserslautern mit diesem Betze, der dann immer bäbt oder keine Ahnung was. Aber sie machen eine Souveränheit, sie strahlen Souverität aus über die ganze Saison. Vor allem natürlich auch zu Hause. Ich glaube Saison übergreifend, ungeschlagen zu Hause. Und in den letzten sechs Spielen nimmt sie vier Siege, zwei Unentschieden. Also, sie fahren halt regelmäßig die Punkte ein und ich finde auch sehr, sehr souverän. Also das, was Florian Kohfeldt, das habe ich mir zu Darmstadt aufgeschrieben, geschafft hat, ist so ein bisschen diese, der hat halt die Defensive stabilisiert, aber nicht gleichzeitig Offensivkraft geopfert dafür. Also er hat das halt mit der Mannschaft, finde ich, sehr gut hinbekommen, dass sie beides kann und auch weiß, wann sie es anwenden muss, in welcher Intensität. Das finde ich hat Darmstadt einen großen Vorteil, zum Beispiel gegenüber Schalke. Schalke fährt sehr viele Unentschieden ein, weil sie halt diese Stabilität und diese Balance nicht immer hinkriegen und im falschen Moment dann halt das Tor kassieren. Und Darmstadt kriegt es halt echt hin, den Kasten dann auch mal dicht zu machen. Also ein 1-0 über die Zeit zu bringen. Oder einfach über die Zeit, übrigens vielleicht falsch formuliert, aber du weißt, was ich meine wahrscheinlich. Ich finde, sie sind reifer als Schalke 04. Aber sie sind unspektakulärer. Auch vom Personal her, von den Namen her. Das ist auch gar nicht schlimm, finde ich. Das war immer schon ein Vorteil, den Darmstadt hatte, finde ich. Um ihnen zu nahe treten zu wollen, sie spielen sich auch in ihrer Außendarstellung, nicht in den Vordergrund, sondern sie machen das auf dem Platz, sportlich. Und das, finde ich, strahlt eine Ruhe aus. Und wie ich gesagt habe, Souveränität, die zum Beispiel auch ein Riesenunterschied zu Kaiserslautern ist. Da wird verbal rausgehauen einer, da wird hier dies und das gemacht. Das ist eine ganz andere Mentalität. Also Momentum meiner Ansicht nach liegt momentan im Aufstiegskampf, im Aufstiegsrennen ganz klar bei Darmstadt.
Finde ich spannend. Also ich glaube, also in der Außendarstellung würde ich schon mitgehen. Das, was verbalisiert wird und ähnliches, das würde ich auch sagen, dass es eher still und professionell was Darmstadt da tut. Auf dem Feld wiederum finde ich sie durchaus spektakulär, weil ich finde, dass sie von der Offensive– sagt was gerne?
Ich meinte ja, also sie sind auf dem Platz, sind sie absolut Souveränität, sie sind offensiv stark, sind auch defensiv stark, sie haben eigentlich Best of Both Worlds in sich vereint. Bin ich bei dir, ne? Also schon, die spielen auch einen guten Fußball. Also als sie in Paderborn gespielt haben, du hast gesehen, was sie können, warum sie da stehen. Und ich finde, sie haben auch den richtigen Trainer dazu gewonnen. Ich finde es auch stark, dass sie das mit dem den Weg so gehen. Absolut beeindruckend. Also ich war nie ein großer Darmstadt-Sympathisant oder auch nicht gegen Darmstadt, sondern es war immer so für mich aus Paderborn heraus, wie für viele andere Paderborn auch, ist eine grauere Erscheinung. Aber das ist gar nicht bös gemeint. Ich finde, das macht Darmstadt aus. Sie machen sehr, sehr viel aus ihren Möglichkeiten. Und wie du sagst, sie haben tolle Spiele dabei, wo du sagst, sie spielen richtig guten Fußball. Sie haben aber auch wiederum Spiele dabei, wo sie selber merken, okay, heute ist nicht so unser Tag, aber dann machen wir es halt über den defensiven Aspekt und holen die Punkte.
Also da will ich auf jeden Fall mitgehen, diese Variabilität im Spielansatz ist definitiv da. Das sieht man ja auch dadurch, wie sie zwischen Dreier- und Viererkette wechseln können und das auf den Gegner abstimmen. Das ist ja schon fast ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal in dieser Liga, wie Variabelmann da ist. Und vor allen Dingen, das habe ich schon öfter gesagt, Florian Kohfeldt schafft das halt und das glaube ich, das wird sie bis zum Ende auch irgendwo tragen. Ob das dann für den Aufstieg reicht, sei mal dahingestellt, aber ich glaube, deswegen werden sie nicht mehr maßlos einbrechen. Er schafft das halt konzeptionell, Räume zu schaffen, Spielsituation zu schaffen, in denen die Offensivspieler glänzen können, und zwar alle. Klar wird sehr viel über Liedberg geredet, aber wenn wir dann mal gucken, denn Fraser Hornby steht bei 10 direkten Torbeteiligungen, Marco Richter bei 9, Kylian Corredor bei 7, Marseiler findet jetzt auch manchmal seine Momente. Also du hast so viele Offensivspieler, die dahingehend einen Unterschied ausmachen können, dass sich der Gegner auch nicht unbedingt nur auf Liedberg konzentrieren darf, weil dann kommen halt andere. Ich mag das Zusammenspiel zwischen den offensiven Außen und defensiven Außen, also wie da überlaufen wird. Also das Lope ist ja sehr, sehr gut drin und Marco Richter und Marseiler sind eher Spieler, die gerne auch mal nach innen ziehen. Also da ist eine Variabilität in diesem 4-4-2 drin, die ich beeindruckend finde. Spannend ist, dass von der Bank, ehrlich gesagt, nicht viel kommt. Also da bin ich manchmal schon gespannt, wenn jetzt zwei Spieler aus der Offensive gleichzeitig ausfallen würden, wie fängt man das auf? Weil Finn Lakenmacher, Semmy Güller und Boizis und Co. machen diese Saison wenig Dampf von der Bank. Korrigiere mich da gerne, Matthias, wenn du das anbefielst. Also da ist so ein bisschen die Frage, halten diese Spieler das durch, auch einfach körperlich, oder fallen dann mal ein, zwei Spieler aus, dann wird es, glaube ich, einfach von der individuellen Klasse her schwierig. Deswegen hat man jetzt auch ein Niklas Schmidt dazugeholt, wobei der jetzt auch lange nicht viel Fußball gespielt hat, aber von der Klasse her passt das wiederum. Und das ist auch ein Spieler, der Co-Feld schon kennt. Also ich will sagen, ich sehe sehr, sehr viel Gutes in Darmstadt. Das einzige Fragezeichen sehe ich in der Kaderbreite. Alles andere überzeugt mich dahingehend zu sagen, die werden bis zum Ende um die ersten drei Plätze mitspielen.
Also was ich noch hinzufügen kann, diese Variabilität, die hat sich auch gegen Nürnberg gezeigt. Also Hornby war lange Zeit kein Faktor in dem Spiel, hat regelrecht schlecht ausgesehen für seine Verhältnisse, wurde dann in der zweiten Halbzeit zu einem Zehner umfunktioniert und da hat er sehr viel mehr Spielanteile bekommen, Sicherheit gewonnen.
Schottische Voltemade.
Ja, so ein bisschen vielleicht. Würde mich sogar super freuen, aber ich glaube, das ist zu weit weg, um real zu sein. Wenn er noch auf den WM-Zug aufspringen würde mit Schottland, das würde ihm sehr viel bedeuten. Also sprich, er war dann in einer anderen Position auf dem Feld und konnte dem Spiel mehr geben. Akiyama rückte ein bisschen weiter nach vorne. Das heißt, dann hatte man da auch die Pasta-Fetten von Nürnberg ein bisschen besser im Zugriff. Und Marseille und Richter haben die Seiten getauscht, sind aber, wenn man das Spielfeld betrachtet, auf der Seite geblieben, wenn das auch in der ersten Halbzeit war. Und einen Ausfall wie Corridor, den konnten sie verkraften. Hornby war auch länger mal nicht dabei, konnten sie auch verkraften. Also einen von denen vorne kein Problem. Zwei würde womöglich schon ein bisschen schwerer ins Kontor schlagen. Aber sie haben dieses Jahr einfach auch eine stabile Achse, also Clefisch Akiyama als Doppel-Sechs ist gesetzt. Pfeiffer in der Innenverteidigung ist eine Bank und egal ob mit Magliza oder mit Vukotic neben ihm. Und vorne hat man halt die torgefährlicheren Spieler. Das heißt, da ist eine Achse, die letztes Jahr erst wachsen musste, die ist jetzt diese Saison da und damit auch ein Faktor, warum sie so da stehen, wie sie da stehen. Was mir aber auch so ein bisschen aufgefallen ist, in sechs der neuen letzten Spiele haben sie jeweils zwei oder sogar drei Gegentore gekriegt und das war zu viel. Das wird jemandem wie Schuhl nicht schmecken, auch jemandem wie Kohfeldt nicht schmecken. Da werden sie verstärkt ein Auge drauf richten müssen, dass da eben wieder mehr Stabilität in der Defensive in letzter Konsequenz ist. Hat jetzt nicht zugeführt, dass sie die Spiele verloren haben. Das ist ja auch schon eine Qualität, aber gleichwohl, das darf ein bisschen besser werden. Und mit Kohfeldt und Paul Fernie als sportlicher Leiter, da haben sie auch zwei an den verantwortlichen Stellen, die sich, glaube ich, auch sehr grün sind und in der Ausrichtung des SVD mit einer Sprache sprechen. Das ist auch schon gut. Und wenn jetzt so ein Mann wie Niklas Schmidt vielleicht auch ein paar Akzente setzen kann im Laufe der Rückrunde, warum nicht? Und ja, ich glaube noch nicht so recht dran, wie eingangs gesagt, dass Darnstadt da ein ernsthafter Contender ist bis zum Schluss, wenn so wäre. Warum nicht?
Das musst du mir nochmal– Entschuldigung, aber das musst du mir jetzt nochmal erklären. Also ihr spielt, habt erst zwei Niederlagen. Okay, ihr vergebt recht viele Top-Chancen. Also ihr schießt viele Tore, aber ihr könntet eigentlich, wenn man sich so die Chancenanzahl ansieht, vergebt ihr sogar recht viel auch. Also wenn da mal jemand gar nicht mehr trifft oder, ich weiß nicht, dann habt ihr ein Problem. Aber ich sehe das alles, was ihr da habt. Okay, Marc hat einen wichtigen Punkt, den hat ich gar nicht so auf dem Schirm. Stimmt, in der Breite des Kaders verletzen sich zwei, drei Eckpfeiler. Wird es vielleicht so wie Korridor oder Bader, dann wird es vielleicht eng. Aber ist das der Zweifel aus dem Understatement heraus?
Ja, vielleicht auch so. Man hat gesehen, was in der ersten Liga alles passieren konnte. Vor zwei oder drei Jahren waren wir auf einem Höhenflug. Der mündete fast zwangsläufig in dem Aufstieg. Dieses Jahr sieht das alles sehr stabil aus. Aber ich traue dem Braten noch nicht so recht. Dass man zwei Spiele von 19 verliert, ist bei mir die Frage, ist das Overperformance oder ist es einfach tatsächlich der Auswuchs dessen, was man leisten kann? Und die Hatta ist jetzt schon ein bisschen weit weg. Aber lasst die mal jetzt gegen Darmstadt gewinnen am Wochenende. Ich würde die Hatta noch nicht freiweg rausreden aus der Geschichte, aber zu denen kommen wir dann ja auch noch.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist jetzt die perfekte Überleitung. Ich habe ja nicht ohne Grund die Teams hintereinander gesetzt. Denn genug der Lobhudeleien, wenn man so möchte. Jetzt kommen wir zu den Teams, denen wir einen etwas negativen Rückrundenstart bescheinigen. All das ist ja auch, da muss man die Brisanz mal rausnehmen. Das sind zwei Spiele gespielt. Das ist nur ein Ersteindruck. Das kann sich alles noch ändern. Trotzdem bin ich jetzt gespannt, wie wir über Hertha reden werden. Denn ich kann ja vielleicht mal meinen Eindruck schildern. Denn ich stehe sehr ambivalent dazu, Hertha in den Negativbereich zu rücken. Rein ergebnistechnisch ist es so, dass Hertha ein 0 zu 0 gegen Schalke vorzuweisen hat und nun das 2 zu 2 gegen den KSC. Und auch da, die beiden Ergebnisse für sich genommen, sind, glaube ich, Ergebnisse, selbst wenn du dich von Anfang an als Aufschlusskandidat zählst, sind das Spiele, wo du sagst, das ginge schon in Ordnung. Im Vakuum gesehen. Ein Punkt gegen Karlsruhe, das ist kein Riesendrama. Und ein Punkt gegen Schalke aktuell sogar gut. Und wenn man sich dann sogar die Leistung dazu anguckt, dann stehe ich dann noch ambivalent dazu, denn das sind beide Spiele, in denen Hertha in meinen Augen sehr viel, sehr verbessert im Vergleich zu vielen Spielen dahin Runde aussah und beide Spiele verdientermaßen hätte gewinnen müssen. Gegen Schalke hattest du genug Torschancen und bist nur an dir selbst und Loris Karius gescheitert. Und gegen den KSC hast du dir, ja, hast du ein Tor selbst verschuldet, hast einen Sonntagsschuss von Sebastian Jung bekommen, der wirklich fantastisch war, scheiterst aber auch dann wieder eigentlich an dir selbst, indem du super viele Chancen liegen lässt. Und das ist sehr, sehr bitter. Und warum man sie dann wiederum aber in dieses Segment rechnen kann, ist, härter kann sich diese Spiele, in denen man sagt, ja, aber die Ansätze sind doch gut und naja, man kann sich doch vielleicht über einen Punkt nicht beschweren, weil sind ja auch Teams, die was können und ähnliches. Diesen Luxus kann sich härter nicht mehr leisten. Zum einen aufgrund des miesen Saisonstarts, in dem man sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viele Punkte hat liegen lassen. Zum anderen, zum Ende aber ja auch der Hinrunde hat viel liegen lassen. Wenn wir uns die Spiele gegen Bielefeld, Fürth und Magdeburg angucken, da hat man zwei Punkte geholt von möglichen neuen. Gegen Teams, wo man gesagt hat, jetzt ist eigentlich der Zeitpunkt gekommen, um zu punkten und die Lücke nach oben zu schließen. Das heißt, den Luxus, sich Spiele leisten zu können, wo man über schöne Ansätze reden kann und über eine eigentliche gute Leistung, der ist eigentlich verpufft. Und nun sind es aktuell 7 Punkte auf Darmstadt, auf Platz 2. 6 Punkte auf Platz 3, Paderborn. Du willst ja eher Platz 2 als Platz 3, weil wissen wir alle, wie Relegationen zwischen 1. und 2. Ligisten oft ausgehen. Und dieser Blickpunkt ist wiederum wieder für gemacht, härter negativ zum Saisonstart zu sehen. Saisonstart, Rückgrundstart, sorry. Und das ist irgendwie eine Melange, die gar nicht so leicht auszufriemeln ist. Denn wie gesagt, man könnte jetzt auch über sehr viele positive Dinge reden, die in diesen zwei Spielen zu sehen waren. Aber Kevin, wie blickst du denn auf die Alte Dame?
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen das Ding der verpassten Möglichkeiten, bin ich bei dir. Also wenn du das erste Spiel siehst gegen Schalke, bist du ja schon drückend überlegen, aber schon. Du hast schon einen hohen Überschuss an Spielvorteilen gehabt auf deiner Seite. Spielst du das 0-0, machst das Tor halt nicht. Jetzt gegen KSC, ja zwei Rückstände quasi. Moralisch passt das, aber auch da, klar, war es eigentlich auch die bessere Mannschaft, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, in meiner Ansicht nach. Und hast es halt dann auch irgendwie durch, wie man immer so sagt, blöde Gegentore, die du selbst vermisst, weil du dann hinterher rennen musstest und dann nicht mehr die Power hast oder den Drive hast, dann noch das 3-2 irgendwie zum Altspiel ganz zu drehen. Ist halt auch blöd, ich meine, da ist der KSC dann schon gut genug, um dann auch so etwas über die Zeit vielleicht zu bringen. Ja, bin ich bei dir. Es ist irgendwie komisch, es sind in Anführungsstrichen zwei Siege und die oben sind ja auch nicht regelmäßig durchgehend am Gewinnen. Dann bist du wieder da drin in der Verlosung, kannst dann nochmal Momentum ziehen, aber jetzt gerade hast du wieder so den Anschluss verloren. Das muss man ganz ehrlich so sagen. Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach auch nicht der Anspruch der Hertha. Das wirst du besser wissen als wir. Man will natürlich wieder ins Oberhaus zurück und dadurch bräuchte man einfach mal ein bisschen mehr Konstanz. Wie gesagt, gegen Ende der Hinrunde hast du das Gefühl gehabt, jetzt sind sie auf dem Weg, sie haben jetzt so diese typischen Favoriten, Niederungen, die du da hast, durchwandert. Und jetzt werden sie schon nach und nach sich die Punkte einheimsen. Ja, schwierig, schwierig.
Und jetzt bist du seit fünf Spielen ohne Sieg.
Ja, krass.
Das ist übergreifend. Das vergisst man irgendwie, weil die letzten vier Spiele alle unentschieden waren. Hast jetzt aber eben auch, wie Stefan Leitl selbst gesagt hat, dir selbst den Druck erhöht durch diese Spiele. Du hast jetzt die Spiele gegen Darmstadt, Elbersberg, Hannover und Paderborn. Und hättest du mal die Siege jetzt gegen Schalke und den KSC, die auf der Straße lagen, mitgenommen, hättest du da vielleicht sogar den Luxus zu sagen, vielleicht da auch mal eher auf das Unentschieden gehen, wenn es spät in der Partie heikel aussieht oder ähnliches. Jetzt musst du in diesen Partien auf Sieg spielen. Anders geht es gar nicht mehr. Und ja, das wissen solche Gegner durch auch auch auszunutzen. Matthias, wie ist dein Blick auf Hertha?
Ja, schwierig. Also ich kenne das aus Fanperspektive, wenn man weiß, welche Gegner vor der Brust sind. Und man hatte im Herbst so einen Flow aufgebaut, dass man sich punkttechnisch schon viel weiter oben gewähnt hat, als dann die Mannschaft nachziehen konnte. Und gerade solche Spiele wie gegen Schalke oder Karlsruhe sind ja dann noch frustrierender. Auch vor dem KSC-Spiel hatte ja Leitl gesagt, Darmstadt hat gestern gewonnen, wir müssen eigentlich heute gewinnen. Haben sie nicht geschafft. Und das ist im Endeffekt wirklich tragisch, weil ich finde, das waren beides überzeugende Auftritte von Hertha. Und gegen Schalke hat es mich so ein bisschen an das Spiel in Lautern erinnert. Und nur damals hatten sie eben 1-0 gewonnen. Und gegen Schalke fiel dieses formale Deitetor nicht. Also war sehr, sehr ärgerlich, da Punkte liegen zu lassen. Und sie haben ja auch einen überwältigenden Spielansatz, der manchmal ja wirklich gut verfängt. Also wie jetzt Karlsruhe vor dem 1-1 unter Druck zu setzen, zu einem Fehlpass zu verleiten, dann innerhalb von drei Sekunden quasi einen Torabschluss und ein Tor zu machen. Und ich glaube, irgendwann auf Sky hatten sie auch gesagt, dass Hertha bis zur 60. Minute gerade mal 10 bis 11 Sekunden gebraucht hat, bis sie den Ball wieder zurückerobert haben. Also das heißt, da ist ja sehr viel Aufwand im Spiel. Und in letzter Konsequenz bringen sie den Ball aber nicht dahin, wo er am Ende landen muss. Also der Sportdirektor von Hertha hat ja auch vor dem Spiel gesagt, man plane jetzt erstmal nicht mit weiteren Verpflichtungen. Und wenn, dann muss er den Kader besser machen, der neue Spieler. Aber er muss natürlich auch finanzierbar sein. Also das heißt, Hertha hat jetzt mit dem Personal, vielleicht kommt doch noch irgendwo jemand, aber prima erst mal, sich auseinanderzusetzen, da das Maximum rauszuholen. Und die Spielanlage und der Spielvortrag finde ich, der stimmt. Aber der Ertrag in Punkt-zu-Tor-Erfolg und damit auch Punkt-Ausbeute, der stimmt eben nicht. Und da ist jetzt für mich auch die Frage, ist es einfach wie so eine Ketchup-Flasche, wo halt am Anfang wenig rauskommt und irgendwann gibt es mal 6, 7 Siege am Stück und dann ist man halt auch wieder da, wo man hin will.
Das gab es ja in der Hinrunde.
Ja, oder liegt das Problem tiefer? Da bin ich jetzt zu wenig drin. Man hat so Leute wie Demme nicht verfügbar, der einfach fast schon tragisch nicht so recht auf die Beine kommt. Dann mit Krattenmacher und auch mit Eichhorn jetzt erstmal Spieler, die man auch gut brauchen kann. Nicht. Dafür gefällt mir Cuisance. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Also er scheint sich auf die 2. Liga vollkommen eingelassen zu haben. Manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen übereifrig und über das Tier hinausschießend. Aber da ist schon viel da. Deshalb, Hertha ist für mich so ein bisschen– ja, du hattest am Anfang der Saison immer wieder den Begriff Black Box erwähnt, in puncto, wenn es darum ging, manche Teams einschätzen zu können. So ein bisschen ist es auch bei Hertha bei mir, weil da ist einfach viel angerichtet, aber es geht nicht so recht auf. Und dem braten traue ich noch nicht so ganz, aber wer weiß.
Das ist halt die große Frage, die auch in der Hinrunde gestellt war, so ein bisschen, liegt es am Trainer oder liegt es am Kader? Das stellt man sich ja oft die Frage. Und ich glaube, es gab schon Momente, wo man die Arbeit von Stefan Leithel oder generell dem Trainer-Team sehr kritisch gesehen hat, weil man eben wenig Spielidee erkannt hat, außer defensiv gut zu stehen. Das muss man ja schon sagen. Also Hertha war zwischenzeitlich das klar defensiv stärkste Team nach Schalke. Das hatte man zwischenzeitlich sehr gut hinbekommen. Wie gesagt, zum Ende der Hinrunde ein bisschen schleifen lassen. Jetzt sah das ja aber insgesamt auch wieder okay aus. Gehen den KSC mal so, mal so zumindest. Die letzten beiden Spiele zeigen für mich eher, dass es ein Kaderproblem ist. Denn Hertha hatte in diesen beiden Spielen eine sehr, sehr gute Spielanlage. Man hat sich sehr gut in den Räumen bewegt. Man wusste, wie man Positionen frei gespielt bekommt. Die Abstimmung mit und gegen den Ball war sehr gut. Dadurch ja auch das Pressing-Tor, was man da erzielt. Kevin Sesser, der den Ball abfängt. Und Fabian Reze, bei dem man das Gefühl hat, der ist irre schlecht in die Saison reingekommen. Er hat es sehr, sehr schwer. Er sah teilweise wie Schatten seiner selbst aus. Aber auch da, er kommt so langsam rein. Er macht jetzt auch Tore aus dem Spieler raus. Das hat ihm sehr lange gefehlt. Das Problem ist aber, du hast den Namen Diego Demme genannt. Der steht symbolisch für die Hala-Probleme. Hertha hat sehr viel Etat gebunden bei Spielern, die nicht zur Verfügung stehen oder nicht das leisten, was sie leisten müssten. Das kann Stefan Leithel nur bedingt ändern. Du hast das ganz große Problem, dass David Kufnatski als Unterschiedsspieler geholt wurde, aber ständig körperliche Probleme hat und deswegen bislang kaum zur Verfügung stand. Wenn er einigermaßen im Rhythmus war, hat man sofort seine Klasse erkannt. Er hat ja auch immerhin schon drei Tore erzielt. Aber es sollten so viel mehr sein. Warum Sebastian Gröning trotz einer OK-Torquote abgemeldet, das weiß man nicht so genau. Aber auf jeden Fall ist aktuell Luca Schuller der Stürmer Nr. 1. Er hat aber auch schon fünf Großchancen vergeben. Allein schon den K... Also er hätte gegen Schalke ein Tor machen können, das müssen und gegen den KSC zwei Tore machen müssen. Und das wird bei ihm mittlerweile fast schon von der Qualität zu einer Kopffrage. Weil irgendwann geht das in die Köpfe des Spielers hinein. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem. Du hast Spieler wie John Anthony Brooks, wie Diego Demme, wie Leon Jensen, wie Krattenmacher, lange Zeit Dudziak und Co., Spieler, die irgendwie in diesem Kader herumwabern, aber aufgrund von Verletzungen nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Viele Neuzugänge, die auch nicht so funktioniert haben, wie man sich das gewünscht hat. Man hat immer noch einen Thorstein-Sonnen. Man hat immer noch einen Kevin Sessa. Das war jetzt das beste Spiel von Kevin Sessa am Hertha-Trikot. Und es war ein ordentliches. Um mal da den Rahmen zu setzen, dabei wissen wir alle, dass Kevin Sessa ein Unterschiedsspieler in der Zeitliga sein könnte. Und dementsprechend muss man jetzt einfach sagen, man zahlt die Zeche dafür, dass über drei Jahre zu wenige Neuverpflichtungen funktioniert haben. Es sind fast alles Spieler, die jetzt funktioniert haben, die entweder vorher verpflichtet wurden oder aus der eigenen Jugend kamen. Also man ist eher über Kenneth Eichhorn gestolpert. Paul Seguin war halt der absolute Wunsch-Transfer von Stefan Leitel. Und man muss auch sagen, er hat das Niveau von Hertha angehoben. Aber darüber hinaus hat Benny Weber, ohne da jetzt zu tief gehen zu wollen, bis auf Toni Leisner, Michael Cuisance und Harris Tabakovic, keinen einzigen Spieler verpflichtet, der als Leistungsträger gelten kann. Fabian Reese wurde vorher schon verpflichtet. Wie gesagt, Spieler wie Martin Darday oder Ähnliches, die waren ja schon da. Und weitere haben ja den Verein verlassen im Sommer, wie Derry Sheeran, Marza, Kenny. Und man hat es nicht geschafft, da Spieler nachzuverpflichten, die Hertha zum einen besser machen, zum anderen aber auch zu der Idee von Stefan Leidel passen, der ein starkes Flügelspiel will, aber keinen gelernten Linksverteidiger bekommen hat, weshalb er irgendwann von Dreier- auf Viererkette umstellen musste und damit in Verteidigern gearbeitet hat. Bis auf Fabian Rehse und Martin Winkler hat man ehrlich gesagt keine Flügelspieler, weshalb Krattenmacher umfunktioniert wurde. Und jetzt Jerry Medutziak, zugegebenermaßen verrückterweise sehr, sehr gut nach anderthalb Jahren Pause funktioniert als Rechtsaußen. Eingeplant war er da nicht. So und deshalb empfinde ich diesen Kader als großes Stückwerk. Diese Suppe muss der Trainer ausdäufeln, ohne ihn da immer aus der Pflicht zu nehmen, aus der Kritik zu nehmen. Und trotzdem sehe ich, dass der Kader unter Stefan Dattel an klare Limitierungen stößt. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem. Und deswegen bin ich auch gespannt, ob sich das noch in der Rückrunde lösen lässt. Denn wie du gesagt hast, Kenneth Eichhorn wird jetzt wochenlang ausfallen, Boris Krattenmacher wird jetzt lange ausfallen, der auch immer wieder mal den Unterschied ausgemacht hat. Man muss beten und hoffen, dass Kovnatsky fit bleibt. Weil das ist dann der Spieler, der natürlich die Torchancen machen kann und dann dieses spielerische Übergewicht gegen Schalke, gegen den KSC auch mal in Tore hätte umwandeln können. So ist es unrund und ich habe aktuell klar das Bauchgefühl, dass Hertha am Ende die entscheidenden Prozentpunkte fehlen werden. Und das ist bitter, weil eigentlich das Feld bestellt war. Aber wie gesagt, man auch gewisse Unrundungen im Kader nicht innerhalb der Saison verändern kann. Und dementsprechend sind wir jetzt einfach mal gespannt, wie die nächsten Spiele sind. Ich habe sie ja schon aufgezählt. Allen voran, das Spiel ist natürlich dann gegen Darmstadt. Sollte Hertha dieses Spiel gewinnen, wie gesagt, dann sind plötzlich nur noch vier Punkte und dann ist man wieder in der Verlosung drin. Aber vollkommen klar ist, dass Hertha jetzt eine Serie braucht. Es sind jetzt noch 15 Spiele und Hertha muss eigentlich realistischerweise 10 dieser 15 Spiele gewinnen, um am Ende aufzusteigen. Und das will ich erst mal sehen. Aber genug zu dem Hertha-Schwerpunkt, würde ich sagen. Und wir gehen jetzt zu einem Team, was deutlich größere Probleme hat als Hertha, wenn man das so bezeichnen möchte, nämlich Greuther Fürth bzw. die Spielvereinigung Fürth. Greuther Fürth soll ja eigentlich nicht mehr gesagt werden. Da möchte ich mich gerne dran halten. Fürth, aktuell Tabellenletzter, die rote Laterne und es brennt tatsächlich lichterloh im Verein. Man hat ein verdientes 0 zu 2 gegen Dresden kassiert und ein schmeichelhaftes 0 zu 0 gegen Braunschweig. Es gab zuletzt ein Brandbrief des Aufsichtsrats und des Präsidiums, die die Mannschaft und die sportlich Verantwortlichen öffentlich angezählt haben. Das zeigt, wie sehr die Nerven blank liegen. Die drei Neuzugänge, unter anderem Paul Will von Darmstadt, Matthias, haben bislang auch noch nicht gezündet. Und so habe ich das Gefühl, dass der Trainer-Effekt auch schon wieder verpufft ist. Drei Punkte aus fünf Spielen unter Heiko Vogel sprechen eine relativ klare Sprache. Kevin, wie blickst du auf das Kleeblatt und auf diesen Rückrundenstart? Hast du jetzt überhaupt noch irgendeine Fantasie, dass sie am Ende die Liga halten?
Also, führt es wirklich gerade sehr. Also nicht nur gerade, sondern die ganze Saison schon und eigentlich auch schon davor. In der Saison wirklich ein Tiefpunkt her ab dem nächsten und es wird komplett konzeptlos, planlos. Teilweise hat man auch gar nicht mehr den Eindruck, dass irgendwer weiß, wer was zu bestimmen hat und wer was entscheidet und wen verpflichtet und nach welchem Konzept das getan wird. Mir fehlt die Fantasie, um das gerade mal so abzurunden, wie führt in dieser Saison, auch wenn unten alles sehr eng ist, das schaffen will. Also, ich weiß nicht, das Spiel gegen Braunschweig, das hast du auch nur 0-0 gespielt.
Hast du auch eine spürote Karte gesehen?
Braunschweig schafft es einfach nicht, Tore zu schießen. Das ist auch so ein, ist ja das andere Problem-Team irgendwie vielleicht auch. Also völlig ungefährlich gegen eine führte Mannschaft, die halt auch völlig ungefährlich und total verunsichert ist. Also da passt gar nichts zusammen. Also mir fehlt komplett die Fantasie, wie es Kleblat auch in der nächsten Zone, noch in der zweiten Liga spielen kann, soll. Aber das große Plus, was sie haben, ist einfach, dass das alles sehr eng beieinander ist. Und ein, zwei Momente reichen, um so ein Negativ-Trend auch komplett umzudrehen. Siehe Dresden gerade mit zwei richtigen Big-Points. Ja, aber ich weiß gerade nicht, wo es herkommen soll bei Fürth. Das ist so, sage ich schon.
Das ist aus der individuellen Offensivklasse. Du hast immer noch einen Furtkoll, immer noch einen Hürgota, immer noch einen Julian Green, einen Felix Klaus. Aber das sind ja die einzigen Strohhalme, die man hat. Weil defensiv habe ich das Gefühl, dass auch Heiko Vogel, auch wenn jetzt ein, zwei Defensiv-Transfers getätigt wurden, den Karren auch nicht aus dem Dreck ziehen kann. Sie haben einmal zu Null jetzt gespielt unter ihm. Das war jetzt eben dieses Spiel gegen Braunschweig. Was vielleicht auch eher daran lag, dass Braunschweig ein gewisses Unvermögen offensiv ausstrahlt. Also ich bin auch so ein bisschen, wir stehen ja auch immer wieder im Austausch mit unserem Fürth-Experten, Michi Fischer an der Stelle erwähnt. Der wirkt jetzt auch nicht gerade hoffnungsvoll. Matthias, hast du irgendeine Idee, wie das noch am Ende ein positives Ende nehmen soll?
Also da sind viele Zutaten bei Sam, die für einen Abstieg sprechen. Du hattest vorhin Paul Wilde erwähnt, der hatte jetzt gleich wohl kaum Möglichkeiten, sich an den Vereinen, an den Kader zu gewöhnen. Der wurde, glaube ich, am Mittwoch transferiert. Auf jeden Fall im Laufe der Woche hat er am Samstag gleich durchgespielt. Der ist ein Spieler, der einer Mannschaft schon Rückhalt geben kann, der viel läuft, der sehr gutes Passspiel hat und der einer Mannschaft vielleicht in so einer verunsicherten Situation was geben kann, was sie braucht. Allerdings, das Spiel gestern gegen Braunschweig war für mich fast ein Muster ohne Wert, weil es einfach über 90 Minuten in Unterzahl war. Da kann man nicht so recht draus was ableiten, finde ich. Dennoch würde ich das als ein Punktgewinn für die Moral verzeichnen. Irgendwann hatte ich zwischendrin auch so ein paar Vibes. In der Hinrunde am ersten Spieltag hat der Braunschweig in Magdeburg 1-0 gewonnen, in Unterzahlen mit einem Glückstreffer. Da hatte ich schon so gedacht, nach einer Stunde immer noch 0-0, vielleicht gibt es ja was Ähnliches für Fürth. Und dann hatten sie ja sogar zwei relativ gute Gelegenheiten, die einen Treffer verdient hätten, wäre schmeichelhaft gewesen, aber warum nicht? Dennoch, ich hatte von den Zutaten gesprochen, ich fand, dass nach der Niederlage in Dresden der Trainer relativ dünnhäutig reagiert hat. Also Heiko Vogel hat da nach der Partie nicht mit Kritik gespart, hat auch davon gesprochen, wir werden die Zügel anziehen, ein anderer Wind wird wehen und da war er gerade erst im vierten Spiel da. Also das erschien mir eher oldschoolig und nicht im positiven Sinn. Wenn man zu solchen Wutreden ansetzen muss, das spricht nicht dafür, dass Mannschaft und Trainer sich hier sonderlich nahe stehen oder irgendwie zueinander gefunden hätten. Gestern wiederum, als Dietz in der ersten Minute mit einer roten Karte vom Platz musste, da hat er ihn dann auch gleich in den Arm genommen, als er vom Platz ging. Das erschien mir dann schon wieder eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeichen. Aber alles in allem, ich meine 44 Tore zur Halbserie, dann zwei gegen Dresden, das ist einfach viel zu anfällig. Wenn sie die Defensivprobleme nicht in den Griff kriegen, dann können sie vorne für den Abstiegskandidaten relativ viele Tore schießen. Das wird nicht fruchten. Dass sie jetzt viel Mittel verfügen, um sich in letzter Konsequenz in der letzten Reihe zu verstärken, sehe ich jetzt erstmal auch nicht. Und wenn natürlich auch noch, wie du schon sagtest, Aufsichtsrat und Präsidium mit draufhauen, puh, also Wagenburg und Schulterschluss sieht anders aus. Deshalb bin ich auch wenig verwunderlich, nicht davon überzeugt, dass das eins ins andere greift und dann in den Klassen erhalten mündet. Und ich hatte mir gerade noch mal als Kevin über Furt gesprochen, hat er angeschaut, wer so die letzten Jahre da war. Also wenn man irgendwie die Trennung von Zorniger vor 15, 16 Monaten sich erinnert, ruft nach einer 04-Klatsche gegen Klub, das will kein Furt-Trainer erleiden. Damit war seine Zeit zu Ende, aber da waren sie nicht irgendwie in der Abstiegszone. Und seitdem kamen Jan Sievert und Thomas Kleine und sie sind für mich seitdem permanent in der Abstiegszone und irgendwann wahrscheinlich vielleicht die Substanz aufgebraucht. Und Heiko Vogel ist für mich einfach nicht der richtige Mann. Ich mag mich täuschen, aber er ist jetzt keiner, der in den letzten Jahren sonderlich viel, glaube ich, auf sich irgendwie positiv im Profifußball vereinen konnte. Vielleicht sehe ich ihn auch falsch, aber irgendwie…
Nee, das ist so. Ich glaube, er hatte so eine sehr gute Saison mit Basel. Ansonsten…
Die ist auch schon lange her, ne?
Sie wissen, sich seine Trainerstation nicht erfolgreich. Sie haben sie eher aus der Versenkung geholt. Und ich glaube, mit Alexander Zorniger zusammen muss man ja auch die Trennung zum Beispiel auch von Azusi nennen. Seitdem habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass… Auch da, es gab sicherlich Anlass für Kritikpunkte, aber seitdem hat sich ja nichts verbessert. Also habe ich das Gefühl, dass man das Gefühl hatte, wir trennen uns von dem einen Mann und dann wird alles, dann wird es durch Handauflegen besser. Aber darunter hat man halt kein neues Konzept etabliert. Ich finde, Kevin hat es ja schon erwähnt, es ist nicht ersichtlich, nach welcher Idee da jetzt gerade gearbeitet wird. Stefan Fürstner wird konstant überfordert. Hatte ja vorher auch so eine Rolle noch nicht inne. Ich finde es auch irre orientierungslos. Es gab ja auch diesen Brandbrief der Fans, die gesagt haben, hier geht es ja nicht nur um den Abstieg, also geht es um die Existenz des Vereins. Man kann ja auch alle Jugendmannschaften, die zweite Mannschaft angucken. Keine Mannschaft von Fürst performt in irgendeiner Weise. Man steht finanziell so schlecht da wie lange nicht mehr. Also es gibt ja keinen Aspekt, wo man sagt, darauf kann man irgendwas zukünftiges fußen lassen. Und deswegen bin ich, also man muss ja um ganz viert fürchten, sollte es zum Abschied kommen, weil dann keine Substanz vorhanden ist.
Also wenn...
Aber das führt vielleicht ein bisschen weit.
Aber wenn sie es schaffen sollten, die Gründe, wie gesagt, erschließen sich mir überhaupt nicht, wie das gehen soll, weil es wirkt total zerrüttet, wie ich schon gesagt habe. Wenn sie es schaffen sollten, müssen sie trotzdem einen Neuanfang im Sommer starten, weil das, was da gerade ist...
Das, glaube ich, mindestens das wissen sie selbst.
Ja, gut. Aber das hätten sie eigentlich... Also das ist, wie du sagst, das hat sich die letzten Jahre schon angekündigt. Und ja, also da fehlt mir einfach die Idee. Es ist so platt, wie es sich anhört. Es fehlt mir die Idee. Und jetzt ist halt wieder nur noch mit Durchhalteparolen und Aurok-Aktionen irgendetwas möglich. Oder wie Matthias sagt, mit so einem schmutzigen 1-0-mal, da gewinnst du drei, ein Dreier holst du auf einmal unerwartet irgendwo. Aber wie gesagt, die brauchen Siege. Und zwar nicht zu knapp. Wenn du gesprochen hast, die Hertha braucht zehn. Also Führk braucht jetzt auch erst mal eigentlich zwei, drei in Folge oder... Also vor allem gegen eine Mannschaft wie Braunschweig, die halt selbst das Tor nicht findet.
Wie gesagt, da spielt die Rote Karte natürlich eine große Rolle. Aber sehen wir auch davor viele wie gegen Düsseldorf und so verloren. Also die direkten Duelle waren da. Jetzt hat man gerade vier Punkte Abstand auf das rettende Ufer und auf Platz 16. Die nächsten Partien werden eine immens wichtige Standardbestimmung. Du spielst zunächst gegen Kiel, die ja auch nicht komplett aus der Verlosung sind, wenn auch am komfortabelsten noch. Und dann spielst du gegen Magdeburg, die ja zwar per se in der Tabelle nicht super gut dastehen, aber natürlich mit das formstärkste Team dieser Liga aktuell sind. Wenn man jetzt mal diese Derby-Niederlage gegen Dresden ein Stück weit ausklammert, also da hast du jetzt richtig Druck. Mal sehen, ob wir bei dem nächsten Team ein bisschen mehr Fantasie haben, ob sie die Klasse halten können. Die haben diese Nullnummer mitproduziert gegen Fürth. Das war nämlich Eintracht Braunschweig. Vielleicht auch weniger das Spiel als das davor. Auch diese klare und sehr, sehr, sehr verdiente 0 zu 3 Heimniederlage. Auch noch gegen Magdeburg. Wie gesagt, Magdeburg bei aller Berücksichtigung der Formstärke des FCM. Glaube ich, dass dieses Spiel schon sehr kritisch gesehen werden muss. Jetzt auch in Kombination mit dieser Nullnummer gegen indispronierte Fürther in Unterzahl. Matthias, wie blickst du auf die Braunschweiger, die ja in der Saison auch immer wieder bewiesen haben, dass sie in kritischen Momenten auch wieder da sein können. Das muss man ihnen ja zugute halten in der Hinrunde. Glaubst du, die können das Kunststück in der Rückrunde wiederholen?
Also wenn zumindest jemand Abstiegskampf erprobt ist in der 2. Liga, dann wohl Eintracht Braunschweig, die sich natürlich gerne mal von da hinten früher raushalten wollen würden. Grüße an Anna. Aber im Moment sieht es nicht so aus. Auch das Torverhältnis von minus 12. Es könnte eine kleinere Hypothek darstellen. Also der Rückrundenauftakt ist auf jeden Fall in die Hose gegangen, glaube ich kann man sagen, weil gegen Zehnviertel über die komplette Spielzeit schlussendlich keinen Torerfolg zustande zu bringen. Das zeigt schon, wo ein bisschen der Hase im Pferfer liegt. Also Braunschweig ist eine Umschaltmannschaft und wenn eine Mannschaft sich hinten mit einem Bus vor dem eigenen Tor wiederfindet, dann wird es schwer. Gleichwohl in der 2. Liga werden nicht alle den Bus parken. Aber es ist einfach zu wenig Durchschlagskraft. Wir erinnern uns, sie haben vor der Winterpause Schalke geschlagen. Da macht man sich den zwei Spielen jetzt wundern, wie das zustande gekommen ist. Gegen Magdeburg eindeutig unterlegen. Magdeburg hat gespielt, wie man Magdeburg früher kannte. Und vielleicht sind sie ja wieder auf dem Weg dahin. Aber das war schon... Man hat sie auch gelassen. Also das war ernüchternd aus Braunschweigers Sicht, vor allem zu Hause. Und jetzt in Fürth spielen sie es halt einfach auch nicht gut aus. Also sie haben es vor der Pause mal geschafft, ein paar Gefahrenmomente herauf zu beschweren. Da konnte man von Pech reden, dass da nicht mit 1-0 in die Pause gegangen wird. Aber in Summe war das viel zu ideenlos, viel zu wenig durchschlagskräftig. Und man hat jetzt Conté verloren in der Winterpause, der jetzt auch kein Torgarant war. Aber ich finde, er hat dem Spiel schon manche Momente gegeben, die einfach wichtig waren und er aus sich heraus konnte die kreieren. Jetzt hat man Ali-Doo geholt. Und der war gegen Magdeburg. Da hatte ich ein bisschen auf ihn geachtet, wie so ein Fremdkörper noch ein bisschen im Spiel. Gegen Viert kam ich gar nicht dazu, ihn zu beobachten. Keine Ahnung, ob er überhaupt im Spiel war.
Er wurde nach 68 Minuten eingewechselt.
Ja, siehst du mal. Also da glaube ich, würde ich im Moment den Pick wagen. Das war jetzt nicht der Spieler, der ihnen sonderlich weiterhilft. Und du hattest auch gemeint, sie haben mal so Phasen, wo sie punkten. Also sie haben so kleinere Läufe und dann aber auch wieder längere Durststrecken. Und ich fühle mir immer noch dieses Pokalspiel gegen den VfB vor Augen, als Braunschweig wirkte wie ein besserer Erstligist. Und jetzt doch so eine ernüchternde Saison zu spielen, finde ich alarmierend. Also ich sehe Braunschweig...
Was ich alarmierend finde, ist, wir sehen das und dann sehen wir Heiner Backhaus, der in jedem Interview nichts ankreidet, außer Mentalität. Also er wird ja nicht müde zu sagen, vor jeder Taktik kommt Mentalität und Einsatz. Das ist mir einfach inhaltlich viel zu dünn. Ja, das reicht in manchen Partien. Und es gibt mal den einen Tag, da stehen die alle mit dem richtigen Fuß auf und sind den einen Zacken frischer als der Gegner. Und dann funktioniert das mal. Aber du musst auch was darüber hinaus bieten. Aber da kommt ja gar nichts. Und das finde ich auch gemessen daran, dass Braunschweig seit Jahren da unten hängt und seit Jahren ja nur über Intensität und wir müssen es mehr wollen kommt, hat man sich offensichtlich für den nächsten Trainer entschieden, der das vielleicht ein bisschen innenbrünstiger vermittelt bekommt als seine Vorgänger, aber letztendlich genau dasselbe fordert und genau denselben Spielstil fordert. Und das ist inhaltlich, finde ich, so unwahrscheinlich dünn. Und deswegen gewinnst du dann solche Spiele wie gegen Viertnich, wo es mal drauf ankommt, irgendeine Idee zu haben. Die muss ja nicht mal fantastisch sein, aber ab irgendeine Idee. Und dazu kommt natürlich, du hast den magischen Namen schon gesagt, sie haben mit Christian Conté vielleicht den Unterschiedspieler ihrer Mannschaft verloren, der zusammen mit mir mit Aydin sowohl die meisten Tore, als auch die meisten Vorlagen abgegeben hat bisher in der Saison, 4 und 3, um genau zu sein. Ich verstehe, dass du als Braunschweig eine Ablösesumme wie 1,5 Millionen Euro nicht ablehnen kannst, vor allem, wenn der Vertrag des Spielers ausläuft im Sommer. Trotzdem ist Farid Alidou nicht die zufriedenstellende Antwort, beziehungsweise nicht alleine, wenn es Alidou wäre und man holt noch zwei andere Spieler mit dazu, um es in der Breite vielleicht aufzufangen, um unberechenbarer zu sein. Da könnten wir drüber reden, das ist ja aber nicht geschehen. Und wie gesagt, nichts ist teurer als ein Abstieg. Dem muss man sich bewusst sein, dass, wenn man den Unterschiedspieler in der Offensive abgibt, dass das deutlich mehr Wahrscheinlichkeit in sich trägt, wieder abzusteigen. Ich finde es irre, uninspiriert auf dem Feld. Also Intensität allein ist keine Spielidee, ich sage es immer wieder. Da hat z. B. Fennich Dynamo Dresden etwas voraus. Das sieht einfach deutlich mehr wie Fußball aus, abseits von Intensität, was Dynamo ja ausmacht. Und wenn du dann so reinstartest, weiß ich auch nicht, ob die Spieler im nächsten Spiel dran glauben, 110% für die vermeintliche Spielidee zu geben. Also das funktioniert ja auch über Ergebnisse, dass du dann brennst und den Gegner nieder rennst. Das hat der Schalke auch oft bewiesen. Es kann reichen am Ende, weil so viele Teams da unten drin hängen. Das kann schon reichen. Boah, es ist aber echt kritisch. Du spielst jetzt gegen Karlsruhe. Da kann alles passieren, habe ich das Gefühl. Absolute Wundertüte, das Spiel. Und danach spielt sie gegen Bielefeld, die mit unten drin hängen. Hui, also das sind, glaube ich, zwei Standortbestimmungen tatsächlich, weil danach spielt sie eher gegen Darmstadt, Elbersberg. Aber das sind wichtige Partien. Bis dahin muss einem schon ein bisschen Angst und Bange um Braunschweig sein, finde ich.
Ich kann auch gestern, also man hat dieses Spiel, in dem man sich gegen ein dezimiertes Team zunehmend schwerer tut und der Kopf wird schwerer. Man hat überhaupt keine Lösung. Und dann wechselt man 90 Sekunden vor Schluss Florian Flick ein. Dann wundere ich mich, was soll das? Also ich hätte jetzt gedacht, man wechselt ihn ein, weil er mit 1,90 vielleicht hohe Bälle verwertet, ablegt oder sogar ins Tor buxiert. Aber doch nicht 90 Sekunden vor Schluss, vor Abschluss der vor Ablauf der Nachspielzeit. Also den Wechsel, der hat sich mir 0,0 erschlossen, weil wenn ich den Siegtreffer herbei beschweren will und sehe in Florian Flick eventuell eine Personalie, die das tun kann, dann mache ich es doch früher, nicht in der 93. Minute oder so. Ja, schwierig.
Schwierig ist nicht als Geduld.
Und dafür bleiben irgendwie ein Robert Ramsack, der Mittelstürmer ist auf der Bank, ein Fabio Kaufmann, der vielleicht mal den Einsprint anziehen kann. Ja, also weiß ich auch nicht. Wie gesagt, Braunschweig unter der Backhaus lässt mich so ein bisschen ratlos zurück bislang. Aber ich glaube, das wird auch bis zum Saisonende so bleiben. Heißt aber nicht, dass jetzt schon irgendein Urteil gefällt ist. Wie gesagt, sie haben ja ihre Phasen, wo es dann vielleicht doch funktioniert und wo sie vielleicht die entscheidenden Prozentpunkte gehen können. Apropos entscheidende Prozentpunkte, die hat Preuß Münzer bislang nicht gefunden zum Rückgrundstart. Stattdessen gab es bislang zwei Niederlagen. Zum einen das bereits erwähnte 0 zu 2 gegen den KSC. Und nun haben sie– ja, Kevin, du hast das live gesehen– das 2 zu 1 gegen Paderborn kassiert. Rutschen, wie ich finde, eher still und heimlich in so eine Krise. Also sie sind jetzt seit fünf Spielen ohne Sieg. Wie gesagt, jetzt auch gegen Paderborn hat sicherlich die frühe rote Karte, die maximal dämlich übrigens war. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man da mit den beiden so lange so oben stehen bleiben kann. Zieh es zurück, dann passiert da gar nichts. Du kriegst höchstens Geld, weiter geht's. Also total vermeidbar. So aber bringst du dich in die Situation, nach einer Führung sogar noch das Spiel zu verlieren. Wenn ich mal vorgreife, ich kriege Minster nicht so richtig gegriffen. Ich finde diese Kaderqualität an einigen Stellen echt cool. So die Batista Meyers dieser Welt. Gleichzeitig ist es an anderen Stellen auch überhaupt nicht gut besetzt. Sie suchen ja anscheinend verzeichnet auch noch einen Mittelstürmer, weil die Chancenverwertung nicht stimmt. Defensiv ist es aber auch nicht gut. Sie haben erst ein einziges Mal zu Null gespielt in der Saison. Sie kassieren sehr oft nur ein Gegentor, aber das kassieren sie halt. Ich finde Münze optisch nie so richtig verkehrt, aber auch selten so richtig gut. Deswegen tue ich mich total schwer, sie zu greifen. Kevin, du hast sie heute gesehen, wenn auch dezimiert. Was für ein Bild machen die auf dich?
Tja, was für ein Bild machen die auf mich? Eins, was mit einem Blitzstart eigentlich gut in das Spiel in Paraborn reingekommen ist. Klar, wäre auch komisch, wenn nicht mit so einem schnellen Tor. Und dann, wie du sagst, eigentlich ein Spiel auf Augenhöhe gestalten als Auswärtsteam, bei einem SC Paraborn, der sich die letzten Jahre schon auch ein anderes Standing erarbeitet hat und erspielt hat. Und dann diese, ja ich weiß auch nicht, also warum dieses Foul begangen wird von Yasi Pashma gegen Obermeier, grobes Foulspiel, völlig, also auch in der Position völliger Quatsch. Ich habe ihn auch nicht im Interview gehört oder in einer Aussage dazu gehört, ob er sich komplett verschätzt hat. Ich habe es auch nicht wirklich greifen können, warum das passiert. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt ist ja klar, dass es dann schwierig wird mit einem SC Paraborn, der halt Tempo geht, der Kombinationsspiel hat usw. Und sofort alle Attribute, die halt eine Mannschaft hat, die oben mitspielt. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Und dann kassierst du halt zwei Gegentore noch. Und das war dann eigentlich sogar noch zu wenig. Weil man aus Münster-Hanar-Sicht natürlich auch ein bisschen Pech, dass der Keeper dann irgendwie krank rausfällt und so weiter. Also irgendwie Münster hat immer so kleine Dinge drin, die es verhindern, dass sie sich konstant erspielen und erarbeiten. Sie haben dann immer wieder einen Rückschlag. Das heißt, der Torwart fällt aus oder irgendwer anders. Eine rote Karte, die man auswärts überhaupt, also zu Hause auch nicht gebrauchen kann. Aber du gehst früh in Führung, kannst entspannt eigentlich aufspielen. Und ja, versammelt es mit eigenen Verfehlungen. Es ist nicht so, dass der SC Paderborn das erzogen hat zu dem Zeitpunkt, finde ich. Sondern das war völlig unnötig, dass du den SC Paderborn so wieder ins Spiel reingebracht hast und quasi auch eine Vorteilsituation gebracht hast.
Man ist jetzt mit 20 Punkten nur 15. Einzähler vom 16., 2. vom 17. und hat jetzt auch wichtige Spiele gegen Nürnberg, Bochum und Düsseldorf.
Sie versuchen halt immer mutig nach vorn zu spielen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dann im Abstiegskampf nachher zu mutig ist. Also sie haben ja, das muss man sagen, auch in Unterzahl heute ein super expectes Goals wert gehabt mit 1,6. Das ist nicht schlecht, finde ich. Vor allem, wenn man in Unterzahl agiert. In aggressiven, mutigen Fußball, das ist alles eigentlich das, was man gerne auch belohnen würde, weil es ist nicht immer langweilig und unattraktiv, ihnen zuzugucken. Tja, aber jetzt Nullpunkte nach der Pause, Platz 15, rote Karte, fehlende Kaltschnäuzigkeit, das kann man auch bei Münster, glaube ich, als Attribut reinwerfen.
Matthias.
Also, die spielen eigentlich wie ein Geheimfavorit, aber die Ergebnisse sind wie ein Abstiegskandidat. Das ist irgendwie ganz komisch bei Münster.
Zumindest zunehmend. Sie haben ja durchaus die zeitlichen Spiele drin gehabt.
Also, sie punkten wie ein Absteiger, ja.
Nee, stimmt. Also, sie haben 6 Punkte in den letzten 8 Partien geholt. Ende Oktober und Sie gegen Kiel. Seither nur noch einer gegen Bielefeld. Und was du sagtest, Marc, ich glaube, da liegt schon der Funken Wahrheit drin. Sie haben einfach in vorderster Front nicht die Spieler, die knipsen. Also, Sie haben im Kader, wenn wir es uns mal vor Augen führen, Oskar Wilhelmsson, den kennen wir aus Darmstadt, der ist ein Spieler mit Potenzial, aber er ist einfach zu häufig verletzt. Also, schlussendlich wahrscheinlich mehr verletzt als verfügbar. Malik Badmas hat einen Kreuzbandriss, Etienne Amenidou kennen wir auch, ist keiner, der eine Saison verlässlich durchspielt überhaupt und dann schon gar nicht erst verlässlich trifft. Also, Sie müssten, glaube ich, auch, wenn Sie jetzt die letzte Woche nutzen wollen, in der Sturmabteilung nachlegen.
Es gibt Gerüchte, also Sky berichtet, dass Sie Jessica Nuncombe ausleihen wollen, den ich ja noch sehr gut aus Berlin kenne, eigengewächs, aber er passt in dem Sinne perfekt zu Preußen Münster, weil Jessica Nuncombes Körper gefühlt nicht für den Profifußball gemacht ist, so bitter muss ich es ausdrücken, weil dieser Junge jetzt mit 25 Jahren wirklich alles schon mal sich verletzt hat, schon Ewigkeiten ausgefallen ist. Sicherlich ein Spieler, der durch Kampf, Dynamik, Intensität ein Spiel irgendwie auf seine Seite ziehen kann, aber bislang auch nicht als der absolute Knipser bekannt, eher so ein arbeitender Stürmertyp, deswegen auch manchmal auf dem Flügel geparkt. Ja, Münster wird auch jetzt nicht mehr die Crème de la Crème bekommen, das ist auch klar und trotzdem, finde ich, passt Nuncombe ironischerweise sehr gut zu den Preußen an.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, es wird sich noch was tun und ansonsten fand ich, die Niederlage gegen den KSC und auch schon die Partie vor Weihnachten zu Hause gegen Elbersberg so ein bisschen eine Blaupause von beiden. Also sie hatten in beiden Spielen genug Möglichkeiten gegen Elbersberg, war es ein 1 zu 1, das Spiel zu gewinnen. Und das eine verlieren sie und das andere spielen sie unentschieden, also hatten deutliches Chancen plus. Sie sind ja auch eine Mannschaft, die einen gepflegten Ball spielen kann. Sie hatten einfach oder sie treten für mich, für ein Team, das jetzt erst die 2. Saison der 2. Bundesliga spielt, treten sie mit einer spielerisch beeindruckenden Selbstverständlichkeit auf und waren gegen den KSC eindeutig hier im Haus und befreien sich auch aus Pressingssituationen. Da kriege ich schon manchmal Schnappatmung. Das funktioniert aber sehr gut. Und dann kriegen sie einen Platzverweis schon gegen den KSC, der das Spiel zum Kippen bringt. Und jetzt gegen Paderborn haben sie auch sich einen Berndienst geleistet mit einem Platzverweis. Also er erinnert so ein bisschen an Braunschweig im Laufe der Hinrunde, die auch Platzverweise wie andere sonst was gesammelt haben und sich da selber im Weg standen. Und Münster wäre es wirklich zu wünschen, dass sie rechtzeitig wieder das Glück auf ihrer Seite haben. Weil ich glaube, da ist schon viel angelegt in der Mannschaft. Und ich hoffe, sie verlieren jetzt nicht den Kopf und werden irgendwann noch über den Trainer diskutieren müssen, weil das ist oftmals auch nicht per se die Lösung. Und dass sie ihrem Stil treu bleiben, aber einfach einen richtigen Abschlussspieler kriegen, der ihnen dann auch die Punkte garantiert. Das würde ich mir, obwohl ich keinerlei Münster-Bezüge habe, aber ich weiß es zu schätzen, wenn jemand versucht, sich über spielerische Elemente was drauf zu schaffen und nicht nur über schnellen Umschaltfußball. Also wenn sowas fruchtet, fände ich es gut. Und was wir vielleicht abschließend noch erwähnen sollten, Christian Panda ist jetzt Präsident inzwischen bei Preußen Münster, wurde zum Jahresbeginn vom Aufsichtsrat zum Präsidenten gewählt. Also nicht die Mitglieder wählen den Präsidenten in dem Klub, sondern der Aufsichtsrat. Auch interessant.
Ich glaube, bei Union ist das auch so. Das gibt es ab und zu mal. Also ja, da gibt es verschiedene Modelle. Matthias, Kevin, da haben wir doch mal zum Rückrundenstand einen richtigen E-Post hier abgeliefert. Zwei Stunden über den Start der zweiten Liga. Mal gucken, wer bis zum Ende hört. Gerne mal in den Kommentaren melden. Würde uns total freuen. Ich habe mich darüber gefreut, dass ihr die Zeit mitgebracht habt, Matthias, Kevin. Vielen lieben Dank. Ich drücke ja auch schon mal auf das Outro. Hat großen Spaß gemacht. Ich hoffe, wir konnten ein bisschen Insights liefern über Edin Dzeko hinaus. Soll ja über alle Teams geredet werden. Ansonsten wisst ihr, Rasenfunk unterstützen, Supporters Club, guckt vorbei. Und ansonsten macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschau.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.